[Musique]
dans cette grande surface plus de la
moitié des vins vient de Bourgogne des
bouteilles choisies par le directeur
lui-même à la propriété c'est un amateur
mais avec des prix qu'il veut
raisonnables sur générique on doit
démarrer sur du rouge on doit démarrer
autour des 6 7 € pour monter jusqu'à du
10 €. les génériques c'est-à-dire le bas
de la gamme les bouteilles sur
lesquelles figure le mot Bourgogne sans
nom de village à titre de comparaison
dans le rayon à côté il y a les vins
d'autres vignobles les entrées de gamme
en côte duô on est sur plus près de 2 €
alors donc c'est sur du rouge sur sur un
B il des cartes 5 de 4 4 € 3 4 € minimum
on a aussi des Bordeaux qui sont à 3 €
mais si on rentre dans les appellations
dans des
a c'est vra que les les car va se
creuser plus vite sur le Bourgogne par
rapport aux autres régions un écart qui
peut-être du simple au double voire au
triple pour un milieu de gamme alors
cher les vins de
Bourgogne dans la région tous les
vignerons réfutent le mot les prix sont
certes élevés disent-il mais justifié
comment c'est ce que nous avons demandé
à un responsable d'une grande maison de
vin de Côte
d'Or chaque pampe a potentiellement une
voire deux inflorescences donc si je
laisse toutes ces grappes et si ça la
floraison se passe bien je vais avoir
une quantité de grappe trop
forte fait ce qu'on appelle les
bourgeonnage les bourgeonnages c'est
retiré des contrebourgeons qui ont
poussé si on les laisse faire et bien on
aura trop de randement on aura un
entassement au niveau des maladies ça
sera pas une bonne chose seule solution
les coup la tâche est simple et rapide
mais répété pour chaque CP et en
Bourgogne les plantations sont denses
10000 pied à l'hectare c'est le double
voire le triple d'autres vignobles le
travail y prend donc deux à trois fois
plus de temps surtout qu'ici en plus les
parcelles sont toutes petites plus une
parcelle est petite avec des rencours
plus ça demande du temps ça fait un
surcoup par rapport à une grande
propriété d'un seul tenant et puis vous
rentrez dans un rang et vous arrivez au
bout du Rang 10 minutes après
voilà et plus on monte dans la
hiérarchie des vins de Bourgogne plus
les charges s'accumulent là on est dans
la cuverie du claufentin où on
vinifie la plupart de nos grands crus et
premiers crus vinification en
rouge contrairement à d'autres vignobles
où on assemble les raisins dans des
cuves gigantesques ici on les parcelles
séparément chaque opération chaque
manipulation est donc répétée autant de
fois qu'il y a de
cuve et pour l'étape suivante l'élevage
en cave là encore on fait du
surmesure en fonction de l'appellation
on aura besoin de plus de temps pour que
le le vin mature la durée la durée pour
un vin plus modeste qui ne demandera pas
forcément trop longtemps d'élevage ça
sera plutôt 9 10 12 mois par contre si
on on est sur des certains villages
premier cru voir Grand Cru on va monter
plus facilement sur des durées d'élevage
qui vont être de 16 18 20 mois voilà un
courant chérri encore par celui du
matériel les fus sont renouvelés tous
les 5 ans et un fus c'est environ 600 €
pièces des surfaces petites au cût
d'exploitation élevé des vinifications
longues par parcelle c'est clair les
vins de Bourgogne sont chers à produire
mais dans la région les terviticoles
également sont chers bien plus que dans
les autres vignobles cela at-il un
impact sur les prix pour le savoir nous
avons pris rendez-vous avec un expert
spécialiste des terrains
[Musique]
viticoles on va d'abord arriver sur la
parcelle pour en faire le tour la
définir avec ces éléments qui sont à la
fois un terroir une exposition mais
aussi un végétal et donc on va vérifier
l'état du végétal on va vérifier aussi
le mode de travail du vigneron donc
c'est un ensemble d'éléments qu'on va
vérifier qui part participe à la
valorisation technique de la
parcelle Olivier Fichet lui est vigneron
avec l'aide de Sébastien jacquem il
vient de racheter cette parcelle qu'il
est en train de planter c'est une
nouvelle plantation sur un terroir qui
s'appelle la CR et qui va donner dans
combien de temps premier petit rapport
de de de raisin en 2017 et ensuite
vraiment une vraie production une vraie
production de
qualité par rapport au terroir une
dizaine d'années 10 15 ans
cette parcelle lu a coûté 10000 €
l'hectare c'est cher pour une terre en
friche dans ce coin de Bourgogne mais
c'est calculé car le vigneron c'est déjà
ce qu'il va en faire c'est un peu un
challenge c'est vrai de pouvoir
valoriser aussi nos bouteilles par
rapport à cette qualité de terroir et
notre objectif c'est de faire des Cu ha
de gamme dans ces terroir des CUV qu'il
vendra 15 à 20 € la bouteille soit de à
TR fois plus que les vins que l'on fait
traditionnellement
Macon
très intéressant le prix d'une terre est
une projection très long terme d'une
[Musique]
rentabilité donc si les prix sont très
chers c'est que des personnes font le
Paris de vendre des bouteilles encore
plus cher demain c'est d'abord le prix
des vins qui fait le prix des
terres le prix des terre n'influe donc
pas directement sur celui des VS
pourtant dans un même village un même
niveau d'appellation l'un vendra son vin
quelques dizaines d'euros son voisin en
tirera quelques centaines d'euros pour
mieux comprendre rendez-vous à
nuit-s-george chez un caviste atypique
Claude Dufour vend presque exclusivement
des vins de Bourgogne dans sa cave il a
plus de 3000 références à tous les prix
mais c'est avec les plus chers qu'il a
le plus de problèmes on à peu près un
tiers des domaines où la production sur
ces dernières années était inférieure à
la demande donc on est obligé de de
limiter les quanttités
pour chaque client ça peutêtre une de TR
bouteilles mais généralement pas pas
d'avantage car c V combine qualité
quantité et prestige la notoriété du
domaine est en effet déterminante dans
le
[Musique]
Prix un élément Corto connaî bien il est
commissaire priseur et organise TR à qu
fois par an des ventes aux enchères de
vin avec l'aide d'un
expert 1500 à 3000 bouteilles sont
proposé chaque fois à la vente souent de
mais toutes n'atteindront pas des
sommets là on est sur du chevalier
montché donc un des plus grands vins
qu'on puisse trouver en en vin blanc à
quel prix vous pourriez espérer le
vendre 93 c'est un petit minésime et le
château de pulini ne fait pas partie des
des producteurs les plus côtés donc on
va être autour de 100 € la bouteille il
y a un certain nombre de critères qui
rentre en ligne de compte comme
l'appellation l'état de la bouteille il
faut que l'étiquette soit en bon état
euh donc beaucoup de critères à analyser
sans oublier le millésim qui est très
important euh et le domaine qui pour la
Bourgogne est un critère principal
puisque vous avez des écarts pour une
même une même appellation qui peuvent
aller de de 1 à 5 d'un domaine à l'autre
et puis une amplitude encore accrue
quand le domaine est en sensé par un
guide ou une revue spécialisée ou
lorsque le 20in est entouré d'une
certaine
légende le meilleur exemple c'est bien
entendu Henry jailler parce qu'il a
toujours refuser les effets de mode
parce qu'il a toujours fait du bon vin à
toutes les époques de la Bourgogne a une
réputation qui perdure bien au-delà de
sa mort et de la fin de ses
vinifications ces bouteilles sont
véritablement les plus spéculatifs du
marché certaines ont en effet dépassé
les 10000 € pièces lors de certaines
ventes aux
enchères là on paye le prix de la rareté
mais de la vraie rareté c'est comment
avoir un vin de 89 ou 90 d'Henry Jaillet
aujourd'hui c'est quasiment impossible
si on n met pas effectivement une
fortune mais ils sont nombreux
aujourd'hui partout dans le monde à
pouvoir se les offrir ces vin
d'exception comme celui produit ici le
plus connu et le plus cher au monde la
roman Conti compter 4000 € pour un
millésimes récent mais il n'y a que 5000
bouteilles par an un produit de luxe
même pour la
Bourgogne